in some cases people do infect
themselves
hi i'm tara smith i'm a professor of
epidemiology at kent state university in
ohio
i study infectious diseases and have
long been interested in zombie
infections
so today we'll be talking about zombies
in movies and rating them for realism
it invades the brain like meningitis
the adrenal glands hemorrhage the brain
goes into shut down
two hours one minute so this one
is mixed so it does have an incubation
period it usually takes
several days between the time that one
is exposed to a virus and one develops
symptoms
it restarts the brain no just the brain
stem
viruses can get into the brain he
mentions meningitis which is actually
about
the outside covering of the brain and
then you would say encephalitis when it
actually goes into the deeper parts of
the brain
so that can happen there are viruses
that cause those type of illnesses
but you know once you're dead you're
dead and even if this reanimated the
brainstem
that still wouldn't quite make sense
because you wouldn't be able to walk
you could could breathe your heart would
beat
but you wouldn't be you know actively
going out you know shambling around
but that anyone who died would also
become a zombie even if they died in
other
mechanisms so that's a little less
realistic i mean yellow fever is one
that people can get very ill be close to
death
and then sometimes they come back and
feel fine and then are dead the next day
so it has
what we call like a biphasic illness it
has different phases and of course back
in the day
before people had stethoscopes and
things like that if you had somebody who
again was very ill with some infection
you know you listen for a heartbeat or
try to feel for a pulse it might be very
weak it might not be detectable
to the average person and so there are
lots of stories
from outbreaks of your bubonic plague
outbreaks of cholera and even also
yellow fever and other types of
infections where
people have been taken out of their
homes putting the you know the dead cart
going off to be hauled to the graveyard
and they wake up in the cars you know
the human body decomposes rather quickly
so it starts out
really from the inside that you have all
these bacteria
you know in your guts in your mouth on
your skin
that's once you die you become a big
food source
so they're the ones that do a lot of the
initial decomposing
and there's nothing you know about this
particular
virus that would stop that they have
these chambers that
have taken you know years and years that
are still walking around
after the outbreak and they would all
just be
bones by that time something would have
eaten them whether it would be
the bacteria that they carry or you know
other rats or scavengers or something
like that
yeah again it gets a bump for the
incubation period
but downgraded for the reanimation so
maybe a five
i mean as a lab scientist it makes me
cringe
you can see the virus is liquid on the
floor and
it would not be aerosolized like that so
you there would be maybe a little bit of
a splash
in the immediate vicinity but there's
nothing
that is making that liquid become
airborne he's in the
blue suit with the helmet and everything
so obviously this is a lab that studies
things that are dangerous you wouldn't
have ventilation going to the rest of
the building
what you would have would be filters in
the the ventilation system
that have very small pores so they can
trap even viruses
from getting out of the building and
then that ventilation usually goes
out to to fresh air so to outside rather
than inside the building
so even if there was a few viral
particles that made it out
they would be diluted when they made it
outside to the fresh air
and not danger to anyone
that also would completely not happen
even in my laboratory
no food no drink in the laboratory
anything at all
there are some animals that have been
trained to detect
certain pathogens so not necessarily
like how they are in
how they would be in in the room air
here but
sometimes dogs or sometimes they've used
like pouched rats
that can be trained to diagnose people
who
are infected like with tuberculosis for
example so they're using more of
the chemicals that humans put off when
they're infected
rather than directly smelling like the
tuberculosis bacterium
yeah this is about a one
he's gonna eject himself we have no idea
which one's gonna work
so they had noticed previously in the
movie that people who are sick
are avoided by zombies so pitt is trying
to
inject himself with something to
basically make the zombies ignore him
and believe that he is sick so they
don't want to bite him of course we're
not trying to hide from
predators like this when we're ill but
there are examples
where we can use microbes to kind of
fight off each other
back before antibiotics were common for
treatment of infections
they actually used injection with
malaria a parasite that causes high
fevers as an attempt to treat syphilis a
bacterial infection
and that actually won a nobel prize in
1927.
today we don't use it anymore because we
do have antibiotics
so what we do use sometimes are viruses
called bacteriophage
that can actually kill bacteria that may
be resistant to the drugs we have
but not quite in the way is described in
world war z
in some cases people do infect
themselves probably the most famous of
those
was dr barry marshall he was an
australian scientist
who won the nobel prize again for
discovering
that a bacterium called helicobacter
pylori
causes first gastric ulcers people
didn't necessarily believe him
so he ended up swallowing a mixture of
helicobacter pylori himself
and then treated himself with
antibiotics maybe about a three
i think the book was much better as far
as far as realism
but the movie took the concept and i
think twisted it a little bit
the chimps are infected infected with
what
rage
the incubation period is basically
instantaneous when blood goes all over
that is how some blood-borne diseases
can be transmitted for example ebola
is a disease that is transmitted by
exposure to blood and other body fluids
in this case potentially even if people
aren't bitten
if that blood goes into their eyes or
other mucous membranes they could be
infected that way as well so that
part could happen but again
the incubation period would take days
for this in animals at least
rabies does cause a lot of aggression in
humans a little bit less
it does cause aggression it does cause
active biting because in rabies it's
transmitted through saliva as well
so not too surprising that a virus
called rage could have those
you know similar kind of aggressive
fighting
yeah so some viruses do cause eye
infections
so basically we a form of conjunctivitis
in this case it's infecting usually
different places of the eye that you
don't typically see with viruses i
again we see that with ebola seen a
little bit with the current coronavirus
also that some people do seem to have
eye infections from that as well
so there are carrier states for various
types of organisms
you don't see it as often in viruses but
you do have things like hiv
that people can have chronic infections
and be infected for a long time
and transmit the virus to others so we
actually do see that
occasionally with blood-borne pathogens
like not only hiv but hepatitis b virus
and hepatitis c virus and they do try to
incorporate some of those aspects of the
biology of the virus so i'd say this
one's maybe a six or a seven
it's been two months since patient zero
took a bite of a contaminated burger out
of gas and gulp
just two months and i might be the last
non-cannibal freak in the country
this is another one that is not a viral
infection
when you're talking about mad cow
disease that's actually caused by what
we call a prion so an infectious protein
one of the things about those is they
they often are ingested
that's why the big scare in the uk many
years ago some
cows infected with this may have gotten
into the food chain people may have
eaten it
and you know potentially could develop
disease that way
but that two-month time frame would not
be realistic at all this
is a condition that takes many years to
develop because what happens is that
you ingest the the prion and it ends up
in your brain eventually and what it
does is
that all of the proteins in your body
have to be folded a certain way
okay so they have you know a long amino
acid sequence
but that's just the first part those
amino acids have to not only
come together you know one after another
in the right way but also have to have
what we call a tertiary structure so
a three-dimensional structure that has
to be a certain way in order for the
protein to function correctly
and so what this crayon does is that not
only is it folded incorrectly but
as it gets into your brain it basically
acts as a template
for other proteins in your brain and
causes them to misfold
and so as those proteins increasingly
are misfolded in your brain
it causes little sections of your brain
to die
so it causes what's called a bungio form
encephalopathy
so that the official name for mad cow
disease is bovine spongio form
encephalopathy
and it basically leads your brain to
become swiss cheese over time it can
take decades
so the time frame is is pretty off here
coming back from the dead is as well
it can definitely cause behavioral
changes you know aggression or things
like that although
you know to the level of chasing people
and trying to eat them i don't think
that's ever been
uh established with any kind of of prion
disease
i would give this one also maybe a
you unless you five down an ambulance is
on its way right now
[Applause]
yeah so this is kind of similar to again
that rabies aspect of it
rabies is probably the only other virus
that we know
that is basically 100 fatal there have
been
a couple of people who were infected you
can
get what's called post-exposure
prophylaxis okay so
if you have not gotten the rabies
vaccine before
and you've been exposed you've had a
bite from
you know a rabid dog or a wild animal or
exposed to a bat
you can get the rabies vaccine
shortly after exposure that can
basically stop the virus from
replicating in your body so that will
protect you from infection
but rabies has a very long incubation
period
you know weeks to sometimes months or
more
so once you have symptoms of rabies
basically it is completely 100 fatal
i mean you would have to get public
health involved really quickly because
they're the ones really with the
authority
to shut anything down so presumably
somebody would call 9-1-1 call police
call ambulance
and it would go from the hospital first
responders
to the public health department who
would say okay we have some kind of an
outbreak here
we would quarantine everyone so that
would be a pretty rapid response
yeah i would give this again maybe like
a three
[Music]
there are some fungal infections that
can affect the brain
but they don't seem to cause the type of
behavioral changes like this
the next stage in the fungus's life
cycle the mature sexual stage
this is a sporangium a seed pod
if they were to open what
the end of the world you know this is
modeled on insect pathogens
where the the fungus infects the insect
and it does change its behavior they
basically force the insects to
to go as high as they can up a tree and
eventually the fungus causes the insect
to just basically be be a host for kind
of that next phase of evolution they
talk about it in there
but basically you had this this fruiting
body that will
replicate in the insect and then kind of
pop out
somewhere of their body from their head
or or elsewhere and then that is what
sporulates
and so when it sporulates it releases
all of the new fungi and then they kind
of rain down
over the colony of insects and can
infect all of those so that's how it
ends up
amplifying we have had fungal infections
that have gone
around the world or around a country so
i live in an area in northeast ohio that
used to be covered by chestnuts
but then they all got a fungal disease
and you know they basically all died
this can happen those can be transported
very easily through the air
so that's kind of the premise of this
that if something was adapted to humans
that was like this cordyceps that
infects insects
that this could be the result i believe
the last of us they have a lot of
different
kind of phenotypes or different types of
zombies
that kind of evolve over the course of
infection
yeah i would say i would give this a six
they don't look like volunteers to me
millions of people are dying for no
reason these men are gonna die to help
us find a vaccine
so i love this show i think z nation is
completely underrated as far as zombie
shows go so some things that are at
least
somewhat accurate here is that we do
have a long history one of
doing experiments on prisoners for many
years you needed something done you went
to
prisons and you went to orphanages
because there were
places where you could get consent
rather easily whether this is being done
legally or not it would be actually very
difficult to do these experiments on
prisoners right now because there's so
many issues of consent
so that is actually kind of accurate but
although hopefully not anymore
you have murphy who is injected with
this serum
of course he gets gets bitten and
doesn't turn so
throughout the show he says he's kind of
not only resistant to the virus but able
to control other zombies which again may
not be very realistic
but you do have people with perhaps kind
of partial immunity to some of these
infections
eight times i was
bitten and did not turn
eight times i was infected by their
bloody saliva sometimes
vaccine protection is complete sometimes
it's incomplete
um that's almost actually what we are
expecting
for the coronavirus vaccine that we
don't expect it will be you know 100
effective but this is kind of what we
see for the influenza vaccine
that it protects people from infection
but not all of the time
but even for people who are vaccinated
get influenza you tend to have more mild
symptoms so kind of what murphy is
seeing here
yeah probably about a two it's pretty
unrealistic especially some of the
scenarios they get into later on
there's a big plane russ why is that
because we're right on top of it
if you're transporting a very deadly
bioweapon
it would likely be in very tight storage
multiple layers probably and
you'd also have like dry ice or
something to keep it cold so exactly how
it was released during this plane crash
is not very clear i think
that water supply the virus would be
diluted
and even further so as it got spread out
to all the people of the town
so you'd have to have a really small
infectious dose for this like one
virus for people to get infected
and then most likely the virus would be
killed off in the water because rabies
is a virus that needs a host to
to amplify it's not typically a
waterborne virus so it's unclear
exactly how that would happen how it
would survive in that water in order to
infect those if you don't have that
knowledge that
no a government plane went down carrying
a bio weapon there and you're just doing
this based on the symptoms
it would take a lot to kind of tie those
together usually when we see outbreaks
of waterborne disease
we respond to them because you have
upticks in
people reporting to their doctors with
gastrointestinal symptoms with you know
diarrhea and vomiting
one of the biggest ever outbreaks of
waterborne disease in the united states
in modern times was in milwaukee
in 1993 they had an outbreak of a
parasite called
cryptosporidium and one of the early
indicators for
that was that all of the like imodium
was gone from stores
people weren't necessarily reporting to
their doctor that they had diarrhea but
they were going out for anti-diarrheal
medicine
i'll put this down at about it too
while he's in that incubation period um
knows that he's going to turn eventually
so this this idea of bringing back
pathogens from history
as you're you know digging into the
ground as the permafrost thaws
can some of these pathogens that have
been locked in ice cores for
millennia or no longer could those come
back yes some of them definitely can
anthrax has caused outbreaks in some
areas of siberia
one thing is that anthrax is a really
hardy bacterium it
forms spores so it's really stable in
the environment
but again we don't know how long those
would last if it's decades or
centuries or longer we're not sure
but i do want to kind of put a flip side
to this
is that when scientists were trying to
study the 1918 flu virus so the one that
caused the last
big global pandemic they found some
samples from this
that were frozen in permafrost so one in
alaska and one in northern europe
in alaska in the 1950s scientists went
up there
dug up some of the people who had died
and who were again preserved in
permafrost for many years
took samples of their lungs tried to
grow them in the laboratory completely
unsuccessful there was no live virus
there
did the same thing with some of the
samples from again northern europe just
about
15 years ago or so so we were able to
get
viral rna from those and that's actually
one of the reasons we know so much about
the sequence of the 1918 flu virus but
could not grow it at all
and so most viruses are more fragile
than
like bacteria so a viral outbreak would
probably be less likely from
you know something that has been long
put in the ground
they're poisoning this land you know
this country changing
sick we all get sick
interrupting nature that's a big problem
in west africa we had
the ebola outbreak a couple years ago
the really big one
and part of that you know may have been
from more frequent introductions of the
virus into the human population
across parts of africa where they're
being deforested now the bats are all in
close contact and they're in closer
contact with other animals in the forest
because there's only this little part of
it left
so there's more potential for
transmission for that virus
to other animals people eat those other
animals people come in contact with that
through butchering them or other types
of things
and so it can jump into humans so we see
that cycle on and on
but maybe out of four i like 28 days
later just because it
really scares me you know i can suspend
disbelief for
for all of the science that's maybe
exaggerated or
are kind of mistled in there but the
story just really freaks me out